the ifs this morning has said that
without spending reductions your tax cut
plans may exceed the treasury's fiscal
headroom would you be comfortable with
breaking your own fiscal rules
my plans do not exceed the headroom i'm
very clear that they are about 30
billion pounds worth of
worth of costings and those are
affordable within our current head room
but what is not affordable is putting up
taxes
choking off growth and ending up in a
much worse position
and many many international bodies
including the oecd say that our current
policy is contractionary it's likely to
lead to a recession and we simply cannot
afford that what i want to do
is put money back into the pockets of
hard-working people i'm here in
peterborough today meeting families who
are struggling with the cost of living
that's why we need to reduce national
insurance that's why we need to
have a temporary moratorium on the green
energy level to reduce people's fuel
bills so we can help families we can
grow the economy and we can grow those
tax revenues in the right way
now you've also said that over the last
20 years economic policy has not
delivered for britain for 12 of those 20
years we've had conservative prime
ministers for two of those 20 years you
yourself were in the treasury was that
policy that you presided over wrong
we have to recognize that we are in one
of the worst global crises for a
generation the covert crisis and now is
the time to think about how we do things
differently and how we
help our economy grow
after this really difficult economic
shock that's why i'm advocating tax cuts
but i'm also advocating broad reform
to enable more investment into britain
to enable more opportunities to enable
more businesses we've left the european
union we need to get those laws off our
statute books we need to do things
differently and we need to unleash all
the potential of the british people
that's what i'm determined to do
do you take any responsibility for the
lack of growth when you were a treasury
minister
when i was a treasury minister i was in
charge of public spending i controlled
public spending effectively
we still haven't done enough though on
unleashing the potential of the british
economy and that is about having lower
taxes it's also about making sure that
we've got the right
reforms in our economy we can speed up
projects like
railways roads we need to be faster at
doing things and we need to look at the
best in the world and make sure we're
matching and exceeding them do you think
that your opponent in this race rishi
sunak could he win an election as a tory
prime minister
i think the problem is that if we
continue with our current economic
policy which is forecast to lead to a
recession it will be very hard for
conservatives to win an election what
voters will judge us on is delivery are
we seeing the growth are we seeing the
opportunities are we seeing the spades
in the ground and i'm somebody in every
government job i've done i've got things
done whether it's at the foreign office
with our tough sanctions regime on
russia whether it's a trade with the
trade deals with japan and australia i'm
somebody who pushes through gets things
sorted out and gets things done that's
why i want to be prime minister this is
a critical time for our country we need
bold action we are in economic
difficulty the whole world is in
economic difficulty it's not time for
business as usual you've talked in this
campaign about governing as a true
conservative
has the current prime minister not been
we set out a fantastic manifesto in 2019
about unleashing the potential of
everybody in britain about leveling up
the reality is we've had covid which was
a massive shock we've delivered brexit
we've delivered the vaccine but now is
the time to realize the promises we made
in that manifesto because people who
voted for us who voted labor all their
lives want something different they
wanted something new they want more
enterprise they want more investment
that's why we've got to keep taxes low
and that's what we've got to do those
reforms
so that we can realize that
post-brexit potential in britain and
just very finally can a prime minister
win back trust from the british people
if they've received a fixed penalty
notice for breaking their own coveted
rules
the thing about me is what you see is
what you get
i've always been honest with people
about what i can deliver i don't make
promises i can't keep
and i will completely level with the
public about first of all how tough
things are going to be
but also the hope that they can have
about the future because i have a
positive vision for britain and i will
be helping families immediately
with the cost of living thank you